[Music]
oh no the phantasmic dragon caught on
fire that's kind of sick actually you
know what
I need people to Riot and um
uh
go crazy at Disneyland and find Walt
Disney's body
I know it's [__] in there we need to
find it can you imagine dude a big ass
Riot just a coalition of people being
like we know he's in there we know Walt
is in there and then he's Frozen right
yeah yeah can you imagine it's like a
news story of just Frozen Walt Disney
and even rolled out on a just a big
crowd
they're Wheeling them out on one of
those [__]
the Coalition of of find Walt has
discovered him they used to like pass
the packages yeah yeah what's it called
what is that thing called
to move heavy [__] yeah dolly dolly yeah
yeah
no I I just did a picture of crowd
surfing it falls off yeah
my family of Walt Disney is massively
concerned
and Walt Disney's like ah everyone's not
white
[Laughter]
JK is that him
no
oh frick
dude his I mean if you were
cryogenically frozen would your head get
inflate
like would you if you're submerged and
held in ice like in a stasis
wouldn't would your body just like well
up
I I don't have no idea you're a doctor
dude come on yeah that's true I feel
like you'd get freezer burn yeah like
you know when you take out like old like
really old ice cream it's got all those
you know like yeah yeah and you're like
I'm not sure if I should eat this yeah
damn dude they unfreeze him and he's
just had Frostbite the whole time none
of his [__] hands and feet work he
just
yeah yeah
we got everything from the knees up
minus the hands do you think he's like
streaming
like he's technically alive right he's
not he's dead
but they froze no that's
word again
really Cody's like they don't come on
what about Austin Powers
Yeah
but people are cryogenically frozen
right
I don't know
Cody's like hold on I got a notification
my spy pants just came in the mail this
is Cody reels and he's gonna die
sometimes yeah yeah exactly I was
planning on doing it
no but I actually thought damn that's a
myth as of 2014 about 250 corpses have
been cryogenically preserved in the U.S
corpses have been preserved so they're
dead but they're just preserving like
the brain material just in case they can
bring it back to life
but they couldn't do that wouldn't wall
died yeah but I think they're I think
there's a real possibility that you
could reanimate re like you could like
basically export the data from someone's
brain eventually and load it into like
an AI or something yeah but I wouldn't
be like the same Consciousness it'd be
something else based on the memories
[__] you're dead what if that's the AI
we're all just the AI memories of of
people we once were yeah yeah
[__] dude
I'm saying though I should not have
taken those shrooms yeah I'm fine though
200 Frozen heads and bodies await
Revival at this Arizona crownics
facility
just a [__] necrophiliac and they're
just licking the ice
just going crazy
dragging his tongue all over that [__]
let me add it let me add it so employee
comes in late he's just sitting butt
naked on one of the ice blocks
what are you doing I think nothing
nothing
cold plunge damn butt ass naked knees
open yeah what are you doing it
just
chilling yo you know what I want them to
do I want them to cryogenically freeze
me and just throw my [__] off the top of
the building
in pieces
nah dude I want it to hit and the ice
magically shatters all around me but my
body's fine
that's just me that I just it's my
corpse just collapses in the street
actually yeah that would be a good like
alt cremation yeah like you just shatter
yeah yeah freezes yeah bury your
cremation I'd rather shatter yes
if I can freeze me and then set me up in
front of like a turret yeah
boom boom bro it's like a six month
process it's like oh what are you gonna
do with no walls but he requested a
shattering
yeah he wanted Dude Perfect to throw him
off a [__] damn oh
okay yeah yeah
just be frozen
when you fall out are you just chunks of
meat
after shattering
no you beat you'd be like the pieces of
the sh like if you were frozen you just
shatter right yeah but it's like you're
in a frozen state so once it heats up
you might just be little giblets oh like
oh yeah no because then when that
happens
you can't like pigs like digest anything
you just let some farm animals go and
they just eat the you know eat the
remnants yeah yeah
a little bunch of goats come through and
clean it up
can we get a video of an eagle dragging
a goat down the side of a mountain
I've always loved that yeah I've seen
that dude I did that I thought you were
joking no dude Eagle goat side of
mountain oh but don't show them don't
show Bambi don't show Bambi bro baby
goat
no
bro they're making this goat look dumb
as hell right now
oh I love that there's no dialogue
either yeah
here we have the American Phoenix eagle
it's hungry
and it sees lunch
it chases a flock of goats down the side
of a mountain
the goats are aware
of their prey of their predator
they flee
I mean how would you even eat a goat
if you were an eagle well you'll see how
no way the one I was thinking of it
wasn't like a baby yeah this [__] is
crazy
oh and then it does this repeatedly like
it just oh yeah dude
yeah
don't laugh it's not funny it's not
funny it's not funny
dude that went from positive for a
second
that went from the goat just being like
what the [__] off me what are you doing
to like
laughs
so quickly
oh my God it's still it's still alive
this is in slow motion by the way where
are you bringing me
where are you bringing me
let me down
that's one way to go man
it's not dead when you're 80 years old
you're just like old and feeble
get an eagle to drag me down the side of
a mountain you dress up in a goat suit
yeah
I found splatt is your head on the side
of a mountain you're just standing there
on the side
[Laughter]
that's like some mid-summer ass death
yeah I gotta write a film into that or
write that into a film where it's just
like they tie up some person
and they put the [__] goat [__] on
him
and now we watch us the eagle the old
dude in a stupid like Halloween goat
costume yes just waiting for the sweet
Spirit Halloween [__]
laughs
take me take me